alors hier j'ai aussi regardé 90 minutes
enquête chez pas pour vous si vous avez
regardé c'était sur w9 on a vu deux
braqueurs volé plusieurs consoles de jeu
pas de chance pour eux mais ils ont été
vus par deux vigiles acquis mais
françois mes chances pour eux hakim et
françois il galère un petit peu à la
traîne avec les presqu'à dans le magasin
je suis dessus mais alors que les deux
suspects s'approche d'une sortie de
secours
hakim comprend qu'il est déjà trop tard
avec quatre consoles de jeux chacun les
suspects viennent de prendre la fuite en
servir derrière frossard galère reçoit
par derrière tu reçois points soit 1
derrière aqtim tempe tout ce qu'il peut
pour les rattraper mais dans la
précipitation ils ne voient pas que la
voiture des voleurs est garée devant ses
yeux
dès qu'il a le dos tourné les malfrats
en profite pour déguerpir
par chance akin croiser l'un de ses
collègues et se précipite dans sa
voiture pour prendre en chasse les
voleurs
j'ai pas naples et que tu t'en fais
chier on envoie dit la vérité voilà ici
on se dit des choses est ce que vous
avez déjà volé un truc
franchement même quand vous étiez petit
ou un truc comme ça vous avez déjà volé
l'orangé volé l'orangé du marchand
non j'ai déjà volé mais en fait c'était
pas fait exprès voilà c'est quoi je me
suis rendu compte quand je suis sorti
que j'avais en fait j'avais la poussette
de mon fils comme ça j'avais mis une
bouteille de champagne
voilà pour finir mes courses comme par
hasard sur foot il y avait les manteaux
pardessus et c'est au moment de passer à
la caisse j'ai oublié le nom et vous
avez simplement je me suis dit oui c'est
bien acquis mais françois baudet la
chercher
je vais vous la livre et qui a déjà volé
un truc qui doivent aider j'en étais sûr
sans faire exprès dans une cabine
d'essayage
je suis parti avec le haut sans faire
exprès donc je suis arrivée chez moi
juste avec le haut et je me suis bas
c'est vraiment trop con donc j étais
lendemain juste pour mac juste pour
voler le ba ba oui bah oui j'ai pris le
bas voilà avant d'aller vous n'avez plus
bas vous avez volé le ba ba de les voler
voilà je connais bien la paire s'avança
se forment séparément aventure en des
lieux où elles payer le maillot oui oui
vous savez tout plu et je le dis on va
pas d'achat déjà volé quelque chose
c'est mal
alors isabelle oms j'ai envie de savoir
ce que vous avez vous allez vous oui des
cerises
non je volais d'esri dans les arbres et
les revendait devant le collège away
affront indépendance pas vrai un franc
le kilo minerai vous étiez le vendeur de
seriner ah ouais j'ai été piqué vous
êtes fait dénoyautées willy's ah ben non
elle c'est un pari entre copines de
piquer des trucs quand on est étudiant
du toujours en grève on avait le temps
et donc on avait petit à petit on
apprenait des choses de plus en plus de
valeur et un jour c'était un manteau et
moi je me suis dit je suis doué je
prends le manteau est tout près à la à
l'entrée voilà et donc comme je savais
rien fleuret et ben
et un pouce en fait trop mais c'est
laurent voulait le rendre en avant le
sens du rythme et copines avec le jeune
oui bien sûr mais moi aussi ma mère
voulait détruire chercher au lycée tu
tombes ne tentez pas gênant isabelle
lachance qui avise avait à l'époque qui
avait pas d'alarmé pas de vidéo
surveillance et berrien vraiment est
toujours pas d'humour
mercy normes israël on va lever le pied
sur les anecdotes à celle du média
rivière médias sur isabelle a vraiment
non mesdames ne peut pas mener des
soutiens-gorge un mois près par mois les
prix c'est un derrière ces attaques
on a bon cachet à tout le monde est
fatigué tout le monde est fatigué oui
moi j'avais acheté un sac chez saks à
new york mais ça très très beau sac et
quand je suis arrivée chez moi je me
suis aperçu qu'ils avaient pas la
bandoulière et donc j'étais super g
n'est parce qu'en fait 1 500 bondit
guerre ce n'est pas pratique dans pour
sa tournée à la boutique ils ont pas
voulu donner la bandoulière
maintenant ils ont estimé que c'était ma
faute que vous l'avez vous lu et relu et
évidemment je les volets elle a volé une
bourde ou les attaques jusqu'à ce but
j'ai un peu peur non maintenant vous
êtes vraiment grave franchement bah
ouais bon castaldi n'a rien volé face à
lui il y croyait avoir il est un truc
hyper seront facilitées petit un truc
est très énervant c'est les pièces
détachées faisait pour la machine à café
quand on perd on casse une pièce non peu
gérez vous la vendre alors plutôt que la
vendre
jeudi ce traitement dans le magasin et
hop je n'ai montrent un petit bout du
résultat connu la dompter machine à café
c'est pas très vieux ouais non non non
non lui la foulée récemment c'est moi je
suis très très fière dont je vole pas il
faut que je me suis fait piquer ses des
potes qui met est mis dans ma poche
ça chante à mesa les sonnets j'allais me
fait rigoler mais moi j'ai trop peur
pour ça mais j'ai un pote qui a fait un
vol
incroyable je sais y'a prescription
maintenant que je peux le dire c'était
le salon de la moto à paris est le
dernier jour quand on remballe tout
toutes les motos etc
il s'habille avec une tenue de garagiste
tenue bleue comme ça il a foncé vers un
stand d'un grand fabricant de motos
comme ça il arrivé il ya eu plein de
gens d intérim et acsta il arrivé là
depuis la moto la retire les béquilles
il n'est pas à tirer comme ça personne
n'a rien dit avec une moto neuve
c'est fou ciné4
un exemple donné tout ce que vous avez
déjà volé quelque chose votre réponse
est dans la phrase merci devrait
maintenant tu as eu ici ah non non non
j'ai pris une paire de gifles
merci vous avez volé qu un portrait neuf
mois en fait j'étais j'étais un grand
magasin dans le 6ème parisien un bon
marché voilà comme c'est très bien j'en
ai plein quarantaine collectionner les
gommes
c'est les grosses fautes des fautes et
eux cherchent à l'abîmer métier où c'est
comme un l'étagère de chez moi j'étais
très fier quarante trois hommes avaient
volé deux gommes que je n'avais pas le
vigile m'a vu alors en plus ce papa est
avocat donc le vigile m'a vu il m'a
chopé et il m'a dit soit tu en es 2 soit
tués soit tu sois tout mêlé de gomme
soft et à l'essor qu'un peu
mais non ils soient j'appelle ton père
soit je te mets une paire de gifles
ouais j'ai dit ok pour la paire de
gifles inspiré dit qu'il me fait pas ce
pas si d'après d'opérer plusieurs
participants de l'est de gaulle et deux
globes et de tom hooper ça se passera
pas comme ça aujourd'hui ça c'est
l'ancien maths qui se déroule au niveau
et j'espère qu'il va revoter des gommes
pour s'en prendre encore merci